in the battle of the bastards that is
one of my favorite episodes of all time
i absolutely love that episode
jon snow
jon snow beats the [ __ ] out of your
character
it was incredibly satisfying to watch uh
uh for some of us uh and i heard that
that kit
didn't hold back he really hit you yeah
i mean he caught me a couple of times
once on the chin with a shield which was
the worst one but like you know i just
said to him
go for it mate and if you wanted to look
at as good as possible you've got to go
for it and if you don't get punched a
couple of times then you're not doing it
properly and i was kind of
so you know you got to do it
and then you got it's incredible and
what i love is you were kind of smiling
the whole time
yeah which i thought was this beautiful
touch you're such a bastard that you
just you're getting hit and you're like
like a ventriloquist dummy it was
amazing until the end yeah
we played with the idea that he actually
it was kind of he got some cathartic out
of this whole thing and that he really
enjoyed it yeah